Remember to start your day with protein
hot chocolate.
66 gram of protein and about 500
calories.
Okay,
here's the story today. Um, we need this
command.
1 hour stream super quick and then I got
to get to the gym. Um, I just want to
take a little look at our profiling
and like finish up some stuff that I
didn't get to do yesterday.
Okay. Uh, yeah, this messed up the
colors of my term somehow.
Where's this?
We are fighting Cuda today yet again.
That's all they do around here.
All right, so this is where we left off.
We had a couple things annotated.
Why? Why does it keep like adding
Yeah, this term is broken somehow. I
don't know how.
Just get a new one.
Use just white noise. Once again, only
here for about an hour today. You've got
um about 18 hours worth of streams of me
fighting Cuda from the last two days,
though. They're on YouTube.
It auto drops you into the puffer tank.
Yeah. You know how you do that? It's
really simple. Just add the start
command to your bash RC.
I didn't actually set it up to SSH to
the container or anything.
right? So, this is what I did here. Um,
does anybody know if this will actually
get me accurate timings?
Welcome, Liberty.
So what I want to do is I want to just
have like tags basically for all the
stuff
and
basically figure out where time is being
spent because
this seems like very little time is
actually being spent in here. Right.
So, where else could time be being
spent? Like, that seems odd to me,
doesn't it?
I guess.
Okay, wait. I have an idea, folks. What
if I do this?
If I do like this,
right, we comment this chunk of code.
Well, basically, we comment everything
that actually does anything.
And let's see if this works. If I can
get SPS without actually doing any ops.
Okay. So this is 49.7
million steps per second, right? Without
doing anything. So
that should imply
that there's roughly 20% overhead being
lost to copying and everything else,
right?
Is this plain insanity?
Uh, I'm going to do a stream on Opus at
some point this coming week. Uh, it's
possible that I'm just blind, but I I
don't know. I think he's gone a little
nutty.
Are I'm not planning on doing it today,
Sigmoid. It's Sunday. I am doing a 1
hour morning stream and then I'm going
to the gym.
I just wanted to do a quick stream today
to like get a little of this profiling
done because it's been on my mind.
Okay. So, this doesn't make sense to me,
right? Because
this implies
80% of the time should be in
in those uh commands that I had. But
look,
cuz you get 10 million steps per second
or a little bit less
when you run the full thing. You get 50
when you're not actually running the
forward or training. But then this
thing, this is in nanoseconds.
Wait, this is even worse.
This has to be measuring overhead then,
right?
Yeah. This has to be like 02 seconds
worth of launch overhead or something.
Uh, that's a Grock question.
But this was a nice experiment because
now we know we actually have an
additional 20% overhead from copies and
uh that's like 20% overhead we can
potentially reduce.
Yeah. What will happen is that we'll
keep getting stupider because we stop
thinking.
I don't know. So, it says something
about humanity that um that the majority
of us, we get these fancy new tools and
we use them to just not think.
I'd way rather have these things just be
like docs for basically aggregate all
example segments of code and figure out
just niche technical things that should
be documented but aren't
I suppose it's like I'm kind of doing
the same thing and that I would like to
be able to use these things to free me
up from dealing with [ __ ] to work on
real problems. But my definition of what
is real problems and what is [ __ ] is
much closer to the hardware because like
I have a ve I have a respect for the
difference that each you know individual
operation can make uh in low-level
programming and how you really really
don't want to delegate at that level.
Perhaps that's the difference.
See, when I said I'm going to do a
stream on it, like I'm going to announce
it will be, I don't know, Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, one of those
probably. I'll announce it a day in
advance so everybody can come to yell at
me and tell me I'm doing it wrong and
tell me how to do it because if it
doesn't work, I want nobody out there
saying, "Oh, you did it wrong.
Yeah, exactly. That's the only reason
I'm bothering cuz I put out a tweet
before that would said essentially, hey,
is there anybody reputable
um who's actually doing stuff this way?
It's like, fine, damn it, Carpathy.
Carpathy is like maybe you know if
Carmarmac tweeted this I'd be like okay
what the hell's going on with the world.
Yeah, this something this jump right
here.
Okay, so this is how this is the small
amount of LLM usage for the day.
Oh, okay. So, this is just a mixing of
two bad things
See, this is why I say that these models
are useless. Look at this. Hallucinate.
Hallucinate.
Right. It's not even This is This is not
me using it to write code. This is me
attempting to use a language model as
fuzzy docs. uh that claims to be
state-of-the-art on benchmarks
and it just repeatedly hallucinates
crap.
Well, I mean, this one works, but it's
not remotely what I like not remotely
the thing that I wanted,
right?
This is not aggregated correctly.
Right. Look at this.
I'll try this one and otherwise I will
do it myself.
Doesn't exist. See, look. Literally
useless.
Waste more time than it saves.
Good. You're super human if you you're
using them wrong. My ass.
Hey, muffin.
It's today.
What's today? No, I'm just doing a quick
I'm just here for like an hour, man. I'm
doing some basic profiling stuff.
I have a different task in mind for Opus
that will be even more fair to it, and I
still think it'll fail.
See I do they actually have like doc
somewhere?
No. See this is all their like annoying
gooey.
See because this is what I want is I
want uh exactly this but the thing is
this here is these are nanoseconds right
so this is 0 2 seconds so presumably
this is just 02 seconds of launch
overhead I want to measure the actual
time taken by this chunk of code and I'd
like to do it uh as low overhead as
possible and seems to be much better
than torches profiler for that because
torches profiler would just grab Eternal
Kevin, my the last several days have
just been like the models sucking super
hard. I'm going to do a stream with
Opus. Um,
and we're going to see. I'm going to
announce it ahead of time. I'm going to
pick a very wells suited task. I still
think it's going to completely fail. And
I'm pretty sure that basically everybody
has just gone insane and become lazy.
Like the world would just be a radically
different place if any of these claims
were remotely true.
I I think he probably has just gone like
I don't know, man. I don't know what
he's been doing lately, but like that
post, there's just no [ __ ] way.
There's no defeat. Like, go on, build
something useful. Like, actually advance
tech with these things. I've seen zero
people actually do it. people mostly
just output garbage
educator that's not giving him enough
credit. So Carathy's
uh Carpathy's tutorial things are worth
like they're way way more valuable than
just educational. They've been
fundamental to like improvements in real
libraries and like honestly his original
policy gradients thing was very
instrumental in clean RL which was then
instrumental in puffer lip. So, it's not
giving enough him enough credit to um
just say it's educational. Making things
simple has tremendous value outside of
just education.
You realize like if they give you a
million dollars, you just don't get a
million dollars to do like you basically
just have an obligation to return them a
ton of money before you get any money.
Investment getting investment is not the
same as getting profit.
Self goal for carpathy
beginner LM course.
I don't know what he's doing with that,
right? Like I can I can greatly respect
one chunk of a guy's work, right, and
think that he's completely wrong in
another area.
I'm allowed to do that
nuance.
I kind of that's kind of what I think
Pepe I think it's like the LLMs are just
they're very seductive in the sense that
they tell you how smart you are. They
make it feel like you're getting lots of
stuff done quickly. You get all these
tweets about, oh, I can code while I'm
spending time with my family and it's
all [ __ ]
It's like everybody just put themselves
on intellectual hospice.
Yeah, but man, like don't chill by like
doing damage to the very stuff that
you've built, you know?
Like all this pro LLM stuff like don't
bother thinking use LLM. It just
encourages people to be lazy and not to
bother trying.
manually instrument their applications.
Okay, this is just in instrument marks.
But the thing that I don't understand is
is this CPU side or is this GPU side?
Right.
best assistants or educators. They're
not though is the thing. They lie
constantly even on basic stuff.
You do not have to go very far before
they completely hallucinate. That's the
problem. That's what I would like them
to be as well. And I think they will get
to be closer to that. But like it's just
completely insanity to think that that's
where they are now. I mean, we see it
literally. It's done this five times in
the last 20 minutes I've been live.
Why is your go to AI Grock?
It outputs fast. You can look at their
benchmarks. You can say, "Oh, it's
benchmarks maxed or not." But they're
all within epsilon of each other, man.
It's like this is like the people who
it's like oh you know like you you're co
not coding with AI right because you're
on GPT like what is it four instead of
40 or whatever they did this every
single generation of models for the past
two years and it never makes a
difference
beginner level intro topic it can be but
honestly I don't even think that they're
necessarily good on that
I would in my view there are very small
collection of educational resources on
various topics that are worth looking
at. Um like if you look at my post on RL
that contains all of my best advice for
learning this stuff, pointing you to the
resources I think are good from my
decade of experience in RL. And you can
evaluate that based on what you think of
what I've built, right? And how you see
me doing my work.
Um
yeah like
it's very very difficult in my mind even
for intro topics like teach me how to
program yeah that's very opinionated
like there is not a very objective way
to teach at least most of programming
and usually the opinionated version is
wrong um like I was taught to program
wrong I had to unlearn how I was taught
to program it took many
I'm not gatekeeping programming at all.
The only gate is effort. Apply effort,
right?
Yeah. For very objective topics uh you
can that are easily verifiable, you can
probably get something.
Rock is dog [ __ ] I agree. But I think
they all are.
I tried um I tried Sonnet the other day
as well because people were telling me
to use another model and it was wrong
too.
Biggest thing I had to unlearn um
object-oriented programming like heavily
objected oriented programming is
horrible.
Like if that's the way you're going to
program just don't get into programming.
It's not worth it. It's a miserable
profession.
See, but hyper like every single viewer
in here is going to come in here and
give me a different answer on their
favorite model. But like and it changes
every two months.
But like in my view, they're not it's
not that big of a difference because
like they all just fail.
Like look what I'm asking. This is docs.
All right.
It doesn't need to be smarter. This is
basically just the
unless there's like a big difference in
what training data they were able to go
scrape.
competitive programming. Um,
I think it's only useful if you really
enjoy it. It's better than lead code,
but I think it's only useful if you
really enjoy it. It's not at all
required. I'd be terrible at it. I hate
solving tricky puzzles.
I'm really kind of a philistine in a lot
like my approach to a lot of things like
I don't like feeling clever by solving
complicated things. I like taking big
annoying things and making them simple
and fast and just work, you know?
Like most of the stuff I build, the
final product looks dumb and basic and
simple, but like if you look at what
came before versus what came after, it's
the improvement is obvious.
Torch profile. Torch profile is slow as
hell. That's what I was using before. I
don't want traces either. I want
aggregate timings and the aggregate
timings from torch have way higher
overhead
ever have to do them. Yeah, if you don't
need to do that to those types of
interviews, there's no reason to ever do
them. You should learn data structures
and algorithms. Um, you do not need to
know how to solve tricky puzzles using
data structures and algorithms though.
Does anybody know how to do what I'm
trying to do? Just uh out of curiosity.
We have 20 people watching. Like maybe
somebody knows. So you see this like
block of code here. This is a CUDA
graph. All I want is I want to get
accurate timings of uh GPU and CPU time
spent in this CUDA graph as a whole
without having to do like kernel level
profiling of everything. I literally
just want to like be able to add some
tags to my code and have like this
block, this block, this block with low
as overhead, low as low overhead as
possible
and then have it be accessible from NSIS
or whatever so I can aggregate it into a
nice little table.
Try clawed code. Why do I need clawed
code? There's no Wait, Kevin, there's
zero context for the project. That is
the entire context. So, can I just try
Sonnet or is that not valid in your
view?
Yan Lun is a scam?
No, I don't think he's a scam. I think
he believes what he's saying. Um, I
think some of his views are off and but
I think you have to give the guy a ton
of respect for his earlier contributions
to the field.
OP, every 200k fan a lot of Yeah, those
developers suck.
Most of the developers do making 200k
are doing negative work. Most of the de
developers making 500k are doing
negative work.
My view of most of the big companies is
they like they have a few guys who are
actually very good um that are doing all
the work and mostly everybody else is
just making their lives difficult.
It's usually like some very good
engineers who could easily just go do
their own company and way make way way
way way more money elsewhere, but they
don't want to do the business stuff and
they don't want to think about product
and they just want to write code so they
kind of stay in the big companies.
Open AAI it's very active like before as
well. So OpenAI in 2019 was the best
place I've ever worked. It made
everybody well it made the average
population at least at Stanford and MIT
look like a bunch of imbeciles. Um, it
was truly truly awesome. Uh, the Dota
team was insanely awesome. There was a
ton of groundbreaking research there.
People were generally nice. Everybody
was talking about AI. Ilia was awesome.
Alec was awesome. Schulman was awesome
on Alos at least. Um, Altman I was never
a huge fan of. I was really more like
Brockman and Ilia, you know, were the
guys that I was respecting. But yeah,
I've always spoken very highly of my
time there. It's just not the same place
anymore.
Yeah. And in that's the thing that's
difficult to convey to people who have
like not been in a space for long is
just how hard stuff used to be, right?
I've gotten to see a little bit of it
because I've been here sit for like what
10 12 years now? No, longer.
Longer.
Um,
and like
it's kind of like a if you want like a a
sort of a shorter term example, if you
look at RL before and after puffer, like
the stuff we're just doing now in hours
would be months of work before. And it
like this getting to here, it's a
relatively short amount of code, but it
was the product of thousands of hours of
hard work.
Can I reexplain the thing? I'm just
trying to figure out profiling then. So,
and I tried Jack Elliot. It just it was
not fast enough. Um,
so I'm just trying to get some basic
profiling for this. I just want to
profile some blocks of code here and get
CPU and GPU aggregate timings without
having to add timings to every kernel
because this is this is a graph, a CUDA
graph. It works, but I need to figure
out like where I'm losing PF and it's
actually kind of difficult to get
accurate profilings. Torch profiler adds
a ton of overhead. Uh default NSIS times
every kernel and doesn't let me sort it
the way I'd like to. It's a little
tricky.
How to get good at research and
engineering? Could I do a PhD? I only
recommend doing a PhD to people who want
to do a PhD. Uh if you want to learn in
general my guides on uh my ex articles,
I have two guides. One on general
programming in ML, one on RL. They have
my best advice.
So I hope Yeah, I don't I don't know if
I met him in person. He seems like he's
very good.
What if I don't mind this pain?
Wait, what do you mean people?
What are people willing to pay for?
Uh, lots of stuff. Like most enterprise
software sucks.
You can either make the same thing but
better. You can make something new.
Opportunity is everywhere, man. The vast
vast majority of people are completely
incompetent. One good engineer can
easily easily demolish a 100 person
likeund 100 people at a company worth of
engineers sometimes more.
Dota team end up shifting. I think that
OpenAI the company shifted their that
team or like late like got rid of Samu
and like shifted the rest of the team. I
wish they kept doing that. I think that
that was that was the biggest mistake
that they're not going to understand was
a mistake was not pursuing that path. Um
cuz they could have gotten they could
have gotten RL to where I'm going to
have RL soon and they could have done it
years ago.
Price offer. Literally pick anything,
man. Literally pick anything.
Pick a piece of software. It's bad.
Like pick a piece of software that
people pay for. It's bad.
In my case, the software was
reinforcement learning libraries.
They're bad.
You have research labs reaching out to
for hiring. Occasionally,
I mean, several of them stopped because
I told them, "I'm not looking for um
positions.
If you're not aware, I do this
full-time. So, Puffer is also Puffer is
kind of like a private lab. All this
stuff is open source, but I also run a
business. We build um high performance
sims for companies
and then we do RL on them.
get load.
You should be able to you should be able
to have basic you should know the basics
of your command line. Yes.
And I'm kind of a funny person to watch
on that because like I use a very small
number of very basic tools. I'm not the
guy that knows every possible command
and every possible language feature and
like every possible, you know, tool. I
have a pretty small set of stuff that I
use and I'm very good at using it.
That's pretty much all I do.
Go to two style exploration.
That'd be awesome.
I don't know if it'll be easy for them
anymore, though.
Reality in the world of hype. Well, I
mean, there is a lot of hype. Like AI is
legitimate. There's going to be awesome
transformative stuff, but like it's not
going to just be trust the big companies
to keep pouring money into making the
models bigger and stop thinking about
anything, right? It's going to take hard
work.
It's a ton of very promising stuff these
days. It's incredibly exciting.
But
are you good at get? Nope. I'm terrible
at Git.
It's very simple. You clone things. You
push things. If anything goes wrong, you
delete your local copy and reclone the
repo.
But it's like, you know, if I can build
the stuff that I'm building or being
this bad in so many areas, what's your
excuse, right? Kind of the idea.
Like, I do not care if I look like an
idiot half the time on stream because
the other half the time you see all the
cool stuff that comes out of this work.
We're at 9 million steps per second
training. Huh? 9 million steps per
second.
You're supposed to be practical
engineer. Look at the stuff I build,
man. Maybe it's the things that you like
the things that you think are valuable
to building things are not the things
that are actually valuable, right?
Like which is more likely? Look at the
product of what I built.
Arl iceberg mentioned puffer only
happened because research back focus and
algorithms. Yeah, everybody focused on
the wrong thing.
Insight compute CLI.
Yeah, I I have it here right this thing.
But like it I have command like docs for
every flag. I don't have an overview
that I see on how to do the thing I want
to do.
I've also just gotten distracted
chatting.
Physical health lots. I'm going to
actually in about 15 minutes I'm going
to go to the gym for a good two hours.
I'm going to try to do a eight minute
pace 5K on the treadmill and then I'm
going to do a bunch of heavy compounds.
combination of well I guess I'm not
doing too much endurance running these
days. Um it depends on sort of the
season of the year so I'm doing shorter
distances at the moment. Uh good but
good chunk of powerlifting little bit of
more bodybuilding style training thrown
in. I kind of switch it up. I have some
articles on X about this as well.
Physical fitness is very important
mentally and for your health as well.
Nvidia is the only company that I
actually would not want to try to
compete with. Like Nvidia actually has
good engineering. Okay. Everybody else
no idea what they're doing.
Like I wonder what the world would look
like if Nvidia built the um the tensor
processing library instead of Meta
cuz like every time I have to deal with
Nvidia stuff, it's chill. Every time I
have to deal with PieTorch, it sucks.
How much am I benching these days?
Before I left, uh, the best was 210 for
10.
NIS MCU.
Wait, you were looking at MCU CLI tool.
Is that different?
Okay.
But wait, is this
More important. Yeah, it's um it's
definitely worth taking. But the thing
is like all right, your health is not
all mental health. Can't work long hours
ever, right?
Get sleep.
do exercise,
but like have a lot of focus on your
work, right?
It's more of a mentality thing. It's
like, do you treat your work as a day
job or not?
Wouldn't listen to Elon, a matter of
fact, any guy with political interest.
Woe and behold, people are multimodal.
You can listen to somebody on one thing
and not on another.
Let me just um
really quick here.
because this is probably the proudest
thing I've ever had on Twitter.
that is actually my best advice on
programming. That will save you a ton of
time if you're new.
It's difficult to internalize the thing
as the extent to which some of the
things that are there are true.
Yeah, I don't make political comments on
the stream that are not directly related
to AI. Um, for that reason, there's just
no benefit.
me. No, it's not important. You can use
whatever editor. I'd suggest anything
that's not like um an AI first editor is
fine.
This is just what I like.
It makes it really easy to work in
containers and on remote machines and
things.
No, we can't manufacture a billion
robots soon. Are you kidding me?
I think whoever told me this, I think is
correct. Who was this?
I don't know if can I get an aggregate
view of this
but unique said nope.
It's a fine thing to know those. I think
it's a pretty marginal difference
though.
Like the most valuable thing is just
knowing how to write good code.
I'm trying I like I this doesn't have
example outputs though. So I'm trying to
figure out if this is the exact thing
that we want.
only these kernels
A range B range
of default domain
but like this doesn't have
Not really sure this is what you've been
looking for.
I just need some like really basic
profiling
like I want to have visibility on
everything is all right like block like
per block of code kernel level if I want
it
wait kernel level profile oh wait filter
per kernel Overhead
is high. Replay of kernels.
Okay. Is this
Yeah. Okay. This is for if I want to
improve an individual kernel. I think
insight is low oversight. Uh okay. So
that's good to keep in mind for when I
need to improve the kernels. Maybe
buy a ton of RAM. I am not giving you
financial advice.
Well, the thing is like, hang on. Cuz I
don't have a super long amount of time.
I really need to be going pretty soon.
This was just a short stream. Ended up
chatting a bunch but then also looking
at this a little bit. Um there is one
other thing I could try here
I think.
So what if I don't what if I just do a
hard device sync right instead of this.
So this is start right.
So we do UDA
device synchronize
and then we do
UDA device synchronize.
What happens if I do this?
Because it's going to record CPU time.
So now it's just going to add together
the launch times and everything which is
annoying.
But that might give me some reasonable
timing data at least.
Pro or anti Elon.
I mean, on the technical stuff, it's
really hard to argue that there's
anybody that's done more
um for the world. So, I think just being
straight anti- Elon is just like
admitting you're an idiot
and like easily swayed by politics over
tangible technical contributions.
self-driving stuff is going to be pretty
awesome. There's like probably the most
impressive deployment of AI in the real
world, frankly. Um, it's a very hard
problem.
Uh, I think I don't think the Optimus
stuff is going to solve autonomy or
anything, but I think it'll be very
valuable overall.
Tons of other stuff obviously SpaceX
whatot it's really difficult to think of
more valuable tech
being a well that's like
which companies have better tech
read your article on advice pretty solid
think time is for practicing time for
engineering but you don't end up
learning too much highle patterns
I think that you actually do move faster
when you use fewer tools.
Think it's Elon though.
So, okay then. Like, why are there a ton
of other companies that just have dog
[ __ ] engineering, right?
I don't say I'm not saying he's an
engineering genius, but uh whatever it
is like he's definitely built companies
that have better engineering than most
of the other companies,
Like if you're going to talk about this
stuff, if you at least read the his bio,
his bio is pretty good and he's actually
got a pretty solid mind for engineering.
I don't know how like how good he is at
the low level, but the structure of how
he approaches stuff is very very good.
one last thing and I got to go, guys.
Okay, this is at least better, right?
Look. So, before we were getting some
ridiculous profile.
Now, this is two and a half seconds,
right?
So, I think this is the full time in
CPU.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. This totally is.
Here, let me add this last one in here
and then and then I'm going to call it
for the stream because I got to get to
the gym.
No hype. I'm in Florida.
Okay, I probably should have just
started with this, but no worries. It's
a Sunday. Um, we still got it.
doesn't understand LM's tech when he
talks about X9.
There's so much weirdness about that
topic now. Like I don't honestly don't
know if anybody does anymore
cuz it seems to me like many of the
people at the top labs have just gone
off the rails completely. So I have no
idea what the hell's happening in that
space and I don't really care that much.
Yeah, that's not that's definitely not
true. alone, Liberty,
cuz that alone does not tell you how to
build things.
Like, go read the bio. The bio is
actually very good. Walter Isacson one.
Okay, perfect. This is what this is the
number that I was looking for. You see
this 5 seconds in train, 5.5 seconds in
train, 2.5 seconds in roll out. And then
what I can do is if I do it with events,
I get the launch overhead. And if I do
it with synchronizes, then I get the
full time. This should let me get a full
profile. Um, I'm going to have to come
up with a nice way to aggregate these,
but this plus this equals 8 seconds,
which is uh 2 seconds overhead from
copies, which is exactly what we found.
This is the first consistent profile
that we have. From here, we can actually
profile individual kernels and other
things. This is a good starting point.
Perfect.
Not planet. There's an awesome gym
around here that's like kind of grungy,
but has literally every piece of
equipment that you could ever want from
the exact company that you wanted. Like
if you actually know fitness equipment,
they have the best stuff. Like every
single piece of equipment. It's awesome.
Um if Top Lab's going off the rails, go
look at them. They're doing LLM
psychology crap. I'm always weird. Jess,
I'm literally about to end stream
because I got to go to the gym. We just
got a decent profile. 68% time in train,
31% time in this roll out, 20% overhead.
We're going to do more optimization
tomorrow, but this was just short Sunday
morning stream to do a little bit of
this in chat. And um for folks who've
been around here, I stream all my dev.
If you're interested in what I do,
puffer.ai, it's all open source. If you
want to help me out for absolutely free,
start the repo. feed the puffer star. If
you want to get involved with
development, it's not actually that
hard. Like a lot of the stuff that new
contributors do is essentially low-level
gamedev and they build cool test
environments for agents and then they
get into research from there. Stuff like
this. Uh other than that, you can follow
me on X for more RL content including my
articles and stuff you can't find
elsewhere. Thanks and I will see you all